so as I mentioned we're going to
describe here how a virus which
symbolizes an innovation that in this
case the virus is HIV comes into a much
more complex system that has evolved to
keep itself the same to maintain status
quo and start to change that system and
become part of the DNA so how does it do
that well let's go with the first step
so cells when they are communicating
with their environment they have things
on their surface that are called
receptors and these actually transit the
boundary and help the cell read and
understand things that are going on
outside these have a pre-existing
function completely independent from
what the virus does but the virus has
evolved to take advantage of these
boundary spanning receptors so H Ivy's
first step is to bind to a pre-existing
receptor that trans it's the boundary of
the cell then it binds to another one
and when it does that the virus is able
to fuse with the surface of the cell and
introduce its component parts so it has
viral proteins it has viral materials
these come into the cell because it
bound to a pre-existing receptor so
that's step one of our learning from HIV
in bringing innovations into an existing
system once it has done that as I
mentioned it introduces its viral
material this viral material is RNA now
as I said in the first video inside of
human cells we have DNA the human cells
don't like RNA for the purposes of
understanding the message HIV has
evolved to recognize that so it changes
its RNA into DNA and it uses its own
viral proteins to make that happen
so it's making its message accessible to
the larger system that it's changing so
that's part of step to make the message
accessible another thing that happens as
HIV changes its RNA into DNA is that it
introduces lots of little changes into
the DNA itself these are mutations and
this makes HIV incredibly adaptable this
is part of the reason why HIV is so good
at spreading and it's so hard for us to
stop it our lesson from for this is that
the message of the innovation needs to
be adaptable so let me just pause here
for a second and say what can we learn
from this this is all very interesting
but what can we learn when we're
thinking about introducing innovations
into human systems so let's take one
specific examples let's imagine now that
this complex system into which we're
introducing something new is a hospital
and this is a real world example
hospitals have to deal obviously with
all different kinds of challenges but
one specific challenge that we've
studied in our team is the patients with
a certain kind of heart attack who come
to the door of the hospital and they
need a certain kind of treatment within
90 minutes so the idea is that these
patients arrive at the door of the
hospital they need a treatment that's
called a balloon within 90 minutes it
used to be that many hospitals in the
United States were having
door-to-balloon times that were much
longer than 90 minutes once that change
is introduced and the patient's get
treatment faster they have much better
health outcomes and much greater
likelihood of of success in and
sometimes it makes a difference for
survival so the innovation in this case
would be introducing changes to the way
the hospital functions so that door to
balloon time is lowered to 90 minutes or
less so how did this Howard this
innovation actually introduced well
first it was brought in by people who
were already boundary spanners so it may
be a cardiologist who had read the
papers in peer-reviewed literature about
reducing door-to-balloon time sometimes
it was a quality improvement officer
whose job inside of the hospital is to
bring a new idea
to help improve processes but always the
innovation came in on a pre-existing
boundary spanner and then the next piece
is to make the message accessible so
sticking with the door to balloon time
example the steps of reducing time from
door to balloon were originally as i
mentioned published in academic medical
journals but those steps needed to be
accessible and understandable to the
people inside of the hospital who are
actually doing patient care so that's
making the message accessible making it
understandable to the people who are
going to be using it and also the
innovators for door-to-balloon time
found that they also had to be flexible
they had to say okay here are the steps
that you can follow to reduce
door-to-balloon time and sometimes
people would say well we can't we can't
do step 3 quite like that okay then
let's change it you're going to keep
some of the core message the same but
you're going to be flexible and
adaptable so that this process will
proceed so from this biological model
have spread something that's evolved to
be very good at spreading we can take
these two lessons about how to introduce
an innovation health innovation into a
complex human system now this is not the
completion of the lifecycle i keep kind
of talking about getting into the DNA
and that's really where HIV is going so
in the next video i'll take you through
the steps we'll put them here about how
HIV actually gets into the DNA of a cell
and that's really the goal that's the
implementation of this change to make it
a permanent part of the system